oh
no
that's so wrong
somehow i'm confused right now like this
is hard i wrote these those are like
part of me ah
i picked nothing you guys pick wow
that's so mean how are you gonna ask me
to do that it's not fair i'm mariah
carey and today i'm with buzzfeed
to rank my songs i'll do the best i can
so you're asking me to choose
between
all i want for christmas is you which i
wrote and
fall in love with christmas which i also
wrote it's like apples and oranges fall
in love at christmas and all i want are
two completely different things it's
like you're gonna ask me if i like
motley or cha cha better are you really
gonna do that can you make it oh santa
versus all i want sorry i hate to be
like creating my own game but that's
what i do if you go with oh santa
they're both like sad you know they're
both like up and peppy i can't not
choose all i want as a song it wins it
beats me i can't fight with it wow
that's so mean how are you gonna ask me
to do that
i have to go with fantasy but i love the
brat remix and we went on to do many
others so i i can't not go with fantasy
odb like me and mariah go back like
babies with pacifiers there's no way i
can't go with that i gotta pick weeble
on together but i love my all because
it's very much from a real place read
the book you'll know what i mean i'm
going with the roof i'm doing something
with the roof right now that i'm a
little excited a little excited about
not gonna say with roo not gonna say for
what but a pretty big moment i mean
i feel like touch my body's a bigger
record what i love don't forget about us
i don't know this is hard i wrote these
those are like part of me like all
represent a different moment in my life
how can i pick them i wrote them these
other people that like didn't
necessarily write their other songs they
could pick him really easy oh that was
great i'm like hi spend time on it
i don't love the live performance of
shake it off i gotta shake you up
because yeah but i love the record we
gotta go with obsessed i love can't take
that away and i love the remix but
outside has a very big significance
outside i think i have to go with hero
kind of i don't know it's not that i
don't like hiro no
the thing is though it's not it's it's
that i didn't write it for me that's why
it's different now what it's become
aretha franklin sang it okay we gotta go
with hero
melt away underneath the stars
breakdown emotions i guess honey lover
boy yikes i gotta go with fly like a
bird if i were gonna listen to one of
them i would listen to make it happen if
i have to keep like i i it's a tie
what am i supposed to do like if i could
only have one for my entire life like
let's say like this is my one song that
i have for the lambs tomorrow probably
all i want are you looking at the
background you can't put christmas in
the same genre as the other songs it's
not fair i want to say there's a cross
between the roof outside we were on
together but i think underneath the
stars it's a tie but i tried you can
check out my new christmas special on
apple tv plus love you love you love you
if you can figure this game out then
please figure it out for me because it
sucks for me that i can't
you